that can stop him now is the clock
because now after this last move if the
queen's come off black is one pawn up
but it's not just any pawn it's that
pawn on the left side
it's two squares away from queening it's
paralyzing the white rook
magnus despite the despite the presence
of opposite colour bishops he's
completely winning this position
and uh wesley down to nine seconds on
the clock and
again totally agree with david
black is just dominating the position
and it's all to do with that pawn
um when you said that's not just any
porn it felt like a marx and spencer
advert
yeah and okay black's rook now trying to
undermine the white rook trying to
eliminate the blockade of black's porn
why is bishop trying to cause some chaos
threatening to take bomb with check
but magnus blocking the white bishop is
that just game over here
there's nothing to be done one second
magnus fights back wow look at that
reaction from magnus carlsen
it is a comeback from the world champion
he wins the second blitz games and we
are heading
to armageddon ladies and gentlemen wow i
love that reaction
that meant so much to magnus carlson
yeah totally i mean i think
this tournament has been so emotional
for the world